first of all thanks for being here hey
my pleasure uh congratulations you're in
order playgirl magazine named you the
second hottest anchor hey how do you
know that uh
big fan of the magazine
i've been in it so many times i thought
i'd check it out yeah yeah the
competitions i beat larry king
yeah
and narrowly edged out sam donaldson i
think we have his theories
he was the centerfold in that issue
it's nice to know there's you know
there's a fetish group for everyone so
yeah i give hope to like you know pale
skinny gray-haired amiibo-like people
right run away no no you're a
fine-looking fine looking fellow well
thanks conan the show's going well we'll
talk later about that we'll go to dinner
discuss it more thoroughly uh but you
must tell us what's going on because uh
i actually never leave the studio you
travel in cover news you just covered
the wedding of charles and camilla i did
yeah i was just in england on saturday
covering the wedding which i don't know
if you saw it it was bizarre it was sort
of um i mean there are clearly you know
there's a lot of intermarriages been
going on over the years and they're all
i don't know if you thought they're all
they're all wearing these it's nice it's
a whole country we're talking about no
no we're talking about the royal family
it does look like the star wars bar
though
we're here for the wedding
[Music]
well they were also all wearing these
hats i don't know if you saw this they
looked like they'd been running through
the forest and like got trees and
branches and twigs gone in their hair
ask what is it about and i i know what
admires britain more than i do love you
guys but um
but uh but what is it their obsession
with giant ugly hats it's bizarre and
they weren't even hats they were
literally twigs and branches like there
were birds nesting in camilla parker
both hair right right right it was very
strange did you have a good time at the
wedding did you it was fun i mean you
know i wasn't actually invited to the
wedding so i was kind of standing
outside but you know there was a
streaker which is always fun you know
what the streaker that country the
streetcars i love the streakers the
streaker was here in this country and a
big thing in like 1974. yeah it lasted
like six months in england it's still
the rage people are always running by at
like royal
funerals like it's a streak
what uh well i didn't get to see you
know his bits and pieces because they
covered him up very quickly but what was
weird is as soon as they grabbed him the
police put a pair of pants on him i
don't know where they got the pants this
the streaker is so common and brave
[Applause]
but then all the all the bobby's posed
with the streaker they were standing
around like yeah they posed with him and
then they brought him back into they
took him in the direction of windsor
castle so i was convinced i kept saying
on air that he was a wedding guest and
that he had just gone like crazy right
and you know decided like to get off the
pants and leave the party and then they
brought him back into the park like
anyone's relative
just running around uh now i i do want
to ask you a little bit your your your
mom uh famous fashion icon gloria
vanderbilt that's right something i
didn't know about you when you first
went on the air and uh she wrote a book
about her life yeah and i'm curious i
don't know how comfortable i would be if
my mom wrote a book about her life well
it wasn't just her life she wrote she
just came out of this book uh about her
sex life basically and it was about all
the guys she's like hooked up with over
the years and and i that's gotta be very
strange well it's a little bizarre yeah
because i used to think the worst thing
in the world was like hearing your
parents talk about sex it's not the
worst thing in the world is learning
that your parents sex life is actually
more interesting than your own right and
uh and you know my mom was like hooked
up with like marlon brando and like
howard hughes flew around so to speak um
and uh
so
uh so to speak so there are you know to
like how do you compete with that it's
like well i don't know you know i kissed
somebody and you know it kind of feel
kind of lame and also then reading these
chapters because she would send me these
chapters as she's writing it and you
know i was fine with most of it you know
i sort of intellectually understood i
should you know embrace her sexuality or
whatever it is right but uh my mom's 81
and there's some things i just didn't
want to know about and she's writing
about things that are happening today
she talked about this guy she's dating
and she describes him as the naginski of
cunnilingus
now i don't know much about
i don't know much about dance but can we
go to commercials now
yeah i know i don't know much about
dance but i'm guessing nigensky is very
limber yes
why explore that area at all
uh
well anyway don't you have to go to
therapy after reading something like
that i know i begged her to take out the
whole neginsky thing but she didn't she
just laughed about it right right and
there's photos in the book i understand
not thankfully of that but uh but yeah
there are some photos
people are filing out right now
uh well let's change topics shall we
that's what any good host would do now
um you were on tv constantly you know
you're anderson cooper 360 you're on tv
all the time but what do you like to
watch in your spare time when you when
you go home and watch television
what do you watch well there's there's
two shows i'm obsessed with one is uh
this show premiere impacto do you guys
watch this on univision yeah yes man
yeah yeah all right spanish tell it's on
spanish television it's on five o'clock
every afternoon and it's it's the most
tabloid news program on the planet it's
basically
it's it's all in spanish which i don't
speak but you don't really need to speak
spanish because first of all the anchors
are totally like busty women in low-cut
gowns and it's all about their legs um
and then the whatever the lead story is
is whatever the most dramatic video of
the day and it can be like a horse that
got hit on the side of the road in
ecuador uh but if it's like just show
that i'll show the video yeah it's
amazing and that'll be the lead story of
the day but my favorite part is that 547
every day they're about is this guy
walter mercado who is a huge astrologer
in the world he's hugely popular uh and
he gives the daily astrological forecast
which uh yeah
he looks like he's completely i'm
botoxed and uh you you think when his
mouth opens botox will pour out of the
mouth but he looks like liberace and
he's very dramatic he has two cameras
and often he's like in the lobby of
caesar's palace and he'll like look at
one camera and he'll be like hemony and
then he'll turn very dramatic and then
go tauros and he'll give the the he'll
give the forecast but you don't even
understand because they're in spanish
but you don't need to yeah
someone told me yeah you brought a clip
of this of this guy i wanted you to see
him let's show this clip from premier
impacto why not take a look
okay that's the best thing i've seen on
television
yeah it's it's gold and he is what is
that called that's premiering
at five o'clock on univision every
afternoon he's at 546 547. i just want
to see that i'm saying yeah it's
fantastic
you